HERE TONIGHT DESPITE JAC CONTINE
FICONTROL.
3:00 GONE BY.
MILLER PLAYS IT AHEAD.
HEREERTIME.
CORY SCHNEIDER GOT HIS FIRST WIN
IN THE NATIONAL HOCKEY LEAGUE IN
MORE THAN TWO YEARS.
>> Ken: THE KID IS
BIG SAVE THERE.
VATRANO.
POINT SHOT.VER THE LINE AND GIVS
TO BRATT WITH A SHOT THATGEORGI.
GATHERED HERE BY KREIDER FOR THE
RANGERS.
ALWAYS AN ENE
IS EARLY ON.
>> Steve: RANGERS DROP THIS
BACK.
MILLER A SHOT THAT WENTTGH, BY
DEFENSEMAN MILLER.
PLAY IT BACK.
HISCHIER COVERING THE POINT.RAN.
IT HAD BEEN ALL
THERE IS SCORED.
IT WAS A PERFECT SONE-TOUCH PAS.
RIGHT ON THE TAPE OF
SEND IN FOR THE RANGERS.
FRANK VATRANO CHASININ
TROUBA.
RANGERS HAVE NOT BEEN SHY ABOUT
GETTING P BUT SAVED.VES TO PANA.
A LOT OF TIME IT COMES BACK TO
HAUNT YOU AND THERE IS THE SHOT
FROM PANARIN.N. OUT BY GEORGIEV.
COMES  CENTER.
GOODROW AE 49 GAMES PLAYED,
26  ISLANDERS.
>> Ken: BRATT INSIDE/OUT TRI GR.
AT THE TOP.
HERE IS RYAN GRAVES.
SHOOTING.
REDIRECTED OORE
DIFFICULT AND THE PASS TALLER.
>> Steve: ODDMAN RUSHANDED BY T
FIDDLER.
MY BROTHER RYAN WHITNEY FROM
DIABOLICAL.
BRAUN SHOOTS AND HE SCORES! OVE.
HE RIPSNCE FOR ZACHA INTO
SIEGENTHALER.
GEORGIEV GOT